-Our first guest is
an Oscar-winning actress
who stars in the new movie,
"Moonfall,"
which hits theaters and IMAX
next Friday.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Halle Berry!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, come on now!
Ah, we love you!
We miss you!
-Hi!
-Halle!
-Oh, my gosh.
It's so good to be here.
I wish I were there,
but I'm here, but I'm there.
-You're there, but you're here,
but you're there.
But next time, I want you here.
We miss you!
-I know! Me too!
-But we love you.
Can you feel the audience?
Can you feel the love?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-There's a lot of love out there
for Halle Berry.
-From that good-looking
audience.
-We have a lot to talk about,
but first I want to ask you --
you caused quite a stir
on New Year's Day,
and I thought this was
very funny.
I just want to know the story
behind it,
'cause I think even Questlove --
-First of all, yeah.
This was not supposed to happen
like this.
First of all, Jimmy --
-Okay, okay, okay.
-I was with my boyfriend.
We were on an island.
We had copious amounts of drinks
at the bar.
-Yes, which one does
at an island.
-We're trying to make it
back to our room,
and we passed
this little chapel.
And we think,
"Oh, let's go in here.
Let's see what's inside here."
So, we go in
and while we're in there,
we get the crazy idea, we're
thinking, "Let's fool his mom.
Let's take a photo of us
and send it to her and say,
'Guess what, we got married,'
and then say 'Not!'" Okay?
So we took the photo and then
after we saw how good the photo
came out, we said, "Let's play
this joke on everybody --
on our friends
on Instagram too.
Let's post it
and then let's swipe over
and tell them it's official,
swipe, it's 2022, right?"
That's how we thought
it would play
and that everybody
would be like,
"Oh, good one, Halle,
good one, Van."
But instead, within five minutes
we got all of
these congratulations,
from like Ava DuVernay
and The Rock.
[ Laughter ]
-Like genuine congratulations.
Here's the joke.
So you put, "It's official."
Right?
Even Questlove put, "Wow."
[ Laughter ]
The Rock!
No, no, no, you don't --
Now you know the joke's not
a joke when The Rock says,
"Congratulations."
[ Laughter ]
"Congrats, you two, beautiful."
And you're like, "Oh,"
but here when you swipe over,
this was the joke --
"It's official.
It's 2022, y'all."
[ Laughter ]
I think it's funny,
but no one --
-Nobody got it.
-No one swiped.
-Jimmy, after like 20 minutes
went by,
we were like,
"We are such [bleep].
Everybody believes this.
We're [bleep].
How could we do this?"
-"We don't mean to do that.
-So many people don't swipe.
I didn't know
that people don't swipe.
Now I'm never doing swipes
ever again
'cause I know nobody
looks at the [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-I want to congratulate you, of
course, not for getting married,
but your directorial debut,
"Bruised."
By the way, I was in shock
to see you looking like that.
[ Applause ]
Great movie.
It became the number-one movie
on Netflix.
Not too shabby, huh?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Directorial debut.
And the soundtrack is great too.
I do know "Automatic Woman"
by H.E.R.
is in Oscar contention.
It's a great, great, great song.
-Yes, it's on the short list.
Like, who knew? Who knew?
-It's great,
but oh, my, she's fantastic.
-Yeah, we're excited for that.
-Will there be more Halle Berry
being a director?
-I hope so. I think so.
I certainly know
I have a lot to say.
And being a black woman,
I think that's the white space.
We need to tell more of our
stories from our point of view.
So I definitely hope so.
-Yeah. Would you direct and act
again in the same thing?
-No. No.
[ Laughter ]
I'm one and done with that.
That was a lot of
a lot of a lot.
-It's a lot of work.
-No. It was a lot.
I will never do that again. No.
-I learned something new
about you today.
Someone around the office
told me that the first time
you got your taste of performing
was doing sketch comedy.
Is that true?
You were at Second City?
-I did. I wasn't trying to do
that though.
I was just there
trying to make friends.
I had moved to Chicago.
I was all by myself,
and I had heard that that was
a good place to meet people.
So I went there, signed up, and
yeah, that's where I started.
And one of the teachers there
said to me,
"You know, have you ever thought
about acting?"
I said, "No, never."
He said,
"Well, I think you should.
I think you have
some natural talent,
some pretty good timing.
You should give this a try."
-I don't think many people talk
about that and, like,
you don't have to go to
these improv classes to be
on "Saturday Night Live"
or be --
but it's just fun to be
a funnier person.
And just go and you meet
funny people
that also want to be funny,
so yeah, you get to hang out.
-You do. And people that are
silly and free,
that's what I got from it.
Even the people
that weren't that funny --
I probably was one of them.
But you have the ability
to just be free, you know?
No restrictions.
And you can say whatever
you want to say and flop.
You can do --
You know, it can be amazing.
It could suck.
It doesn't matter.
It's just about being free,
and I love that.
-Congrats on "Moonfall,"
by the way.
I just love even the title
before I saw the movie.
I just thought It sounds like
a great movie -- "Moonfall."
But this is big.
It is action-packed.
I mentioned earlier it's in
theaters, but it's also in IMAX,
which, man,
there's nothing like that.
If you see a giant action,
beautiful movie in IMAX,
it's like, "Ah."
-This is a perfect movie
for IMAX.
I mean, you want to see
the moon, you know,
coming at you in IMAX.
-Yeah, exactly right, yeah.
How do we set it up
for everyone, "Moonfall"?
-Well, this is a story about --
I play a woman who used to be
an astronaut.
She's now working sort of
in the offices now of NASA.
And her old partner comes to her
and tells her that
he's figured out
a big, huge problem
that Earth is going to have,
and that is that the moon
is off its axis and it's going
to plummet into Earth,
and so he and I have to get
together and we have to
figure out a way to save Earth
by stopping the moon.
-That's exactly right. Come on!
That's what I'm talking about!
-You know, something easy like
that.
-Come on!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Halle Berry
in "Moonfall."
Take a look at this.
-Don't argue.
Just pack your stuff.
We're leaving.
-So you're just going to quit?
-What do you want me to do?
-I want you to help us
figure out
what the hell this thing is
so we can beat it.
-We're not equipped for that.
You've seen what
we're up against.
You've been gunning for my job
for a while, Fowler.
Congrats. It's yours.
-What are you not telling me?
You've got Q clearance.
The hole is in the Mare Crisium.
That's what the Harper hearings
were all about.
-You should pay a visit to
Holdenfield.
Here's your clearance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mm-hmm! Yeah!
More with Halle Berry when
we come back, everybody.
We're going to do something fun.
Come on back.